[Music]
so some of you may have read or at least
heard about the very first Avengers for
synopsis that was released if you
haven't don't worry I will read it to
you and then go over in just a second
the synopsis seems to be very legit as
it was released in a brand new issue of
license global before we dive into it
that subscribe button looks very
tempting doesn't it and not to mention
if you hit it you are entered into our
speaker system giveaway the rest of the
details are in the description below so
for those of you who have not heard the
synopsis yet here it goes it reads a
culmination of 22 interconnected films
the fourth installment of the Avenger
saga will draw audiences to witness the
turning point of this epic journey our
beloved heroes will truly understand how
fragile this reality is and the
sacrifices that must be made to uphold
it so that's it that's the first
synopsis given to us about Avengers 4 so
what does this mean it's very short but
there a couple key takeaways here so
first is the rather vague description of
the turning point now it's been said
that infinity war and Avengers 4 are
going to finish what the MCU started
meaning any storyline right now in the
MCU remaining open will come to an end
so a turning point that could mean a lot
it could very well be the fact that the
Avengers just lost
Thanos defeated them and it wasn't a
defeat like when they fought Ultron
Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch for
the first time it was a defeat that
resulted in lives lost millions of lives
were erased from existence and some of
the Avengers and other heroes were
included in those lives lost that's a
really big turning point especially when
you consider that that has never
happened in the MCU but also again
they're wrapping up the stories that the
MCU started so a turning point could
very well be some characters dying for
good and that actually fits right into
the second key takeaway of this and that
is sacrifices
sacrifices to uphold their reality
because again they lost that's never
happened before and I think that reality
is they live in this world where since
the MCU started there are superheroes
that protect the world and the people
from very bad things happening because
our heroes have always won and lives on
a large scale have never been lost
whether it's the hero going one-on-one
with a villain such as
whiplash the destroyer hella Iron Monger
Red Skull or it's the Avengers as a team
going against somebody such as Loki into
Chitauri and Ultron they've always won
they've always prevailed and this is
their reality that they live in the fact
that when a villain comes and threatens
millions of lives they can stop him to
me this is the reality that they're
going to have to make sacrifices to
protect and to me the first thing I
think of when I hear sacrifice is one of
the Avengers having to sacrifice another
Avenger to retrieve the soul stone so it
seems pretty clear that there going to
be some permanent deaths in Avengers 4
and although we can't be sure who there
are some actors that have chosen to not
renew their contracts to play certain
characters so that is it for the
synopsis breakdown let me know what you
guys think and let me know if we're on
the same page or if you're thinking
something totally and completely
different there's obviously so much
speculation and so many theories that
could come from this this is just one of
them I want to know your thoughts and if
you have any theories of your own let me
know in the comments below and also feel
free to tweet at me if you enjoyed this
video I would very much appreciate you
clicking that like button and also if
you would like to see videos similar to
this hit that subscribe button as well
thank you so much for watching woof woof